you're in charge of it how high do you
go I'd go to 20ma I bar I don't know not
a hundred now maybe not a hundred but
everybody could be making hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year that'd be
cool
too many raising the minimum wage seems
like a no-brainer it certainly did to
the people we talked to in Silverlake a
trendy hipster enclave in los angeles if
the forest workers can simply make more
money per hour they'll be lifted out of
poverty right so would you mind just you
know choose putting an X next to the
minimum wage that you'd like to see
definitely not five dollars probably not
a hundred dollars
I don't know I'm guessing 15 kind of
seems about right probably 15 16 dollars
an hour maybe even 17
let's go 18 an hour what a laugh that is
woo let's go $25 an hour make it
something real $15 an hour's sustenance
wages but what supporters change their
minds if drastic wage hikes resulted in
some nasty unintended consequences both
for the poor and for others honestly you
know we're just gonna raise and then
everything around it's gonna raise so I
don't know if it makes too much of a
difference so what do you think the
level of minimum white should be I don't
know she's in good company a majority of
economists agree that minimum wage hikes
caused some increase in unemployment but
the exact outcomes of a particular hike
could vary wildly from one local economy
to the next and the results are
difficult if not impossible to determine
even as he was signing the new $15
minimum wage into law recently
California Governor Jerry Brown still
seemed a little ambivalent economically
minimum wages may not make sense but
morally and socially and politically
they make every sense because it binds
the community together I don't know what
makes economic sense I don't know I
don't know if I necessarily agree with
that I think that it will be a big and a
big adjustment but people will survive
like they always do and so do you think
that there's a possibility if you raise
it too high that people like in you know
summer jobs or for kids or just
entry-level positions that they might
have a tougher time getting a job they
probably will because then they'll be I
guess supervisors or hiring managers
will start looking more at experience or
education because they're paying a
little bit more there's evidence that
young inexperienced workers are some of
the hardest hit by minimum wage hikes
New Zealand acted as a sort of natural
experiment when the government stopped
allowing lower wages for younger
part-time workers youth unemployment
skyrocketed while the rate held steady
among older workers a similar spike in
unemployment happened when England
raised the minimum wage for young
workers and it's not just the young the
people most likely to lose job prospects
or ours are the very people the minimum
wage is supposed to help a 2014
Congressional Budget Office report
estimated that
increase in the federal minimum wage
from its current 725 an hour to 1010 an
hour would lead to the loss of a half a
million jobs mostly among America's
poorest workers and most economic
analyses find no connection between a
higher minimum wage and reductions in
poverty progress causes pain sometimes I
guess and if it cost a few jobs that'd
be fine overall I think would be good
though we need to do it do you think at
the end of the day that it would be
better for let's say lower-income people
or in entry-level jobs to raise the wage
even if they might some of them might
lose their jobs or have fewer hours I
think overall it would be a better thing
so if people lose their jobs or would
you still like to see the non wage
double mmm no not really I mean then
there just be more unemployment right
then so it all kind of doesn't work out
that way either Silverlake is a part of
la known for its quirky local businesses
and its coffee shops the kind of place
where people are willing to pay a
premium to avoid products deemed overly
corporate where is that from this is
from intelligentsia cafe what's that it
is a coffee shop right here local right
here local why do you like it cuz it's
great quality it's local I've been
coming here since the day they open is
it expensive how much was that uh for
most people they would consider this
expensive it was 950 for a cup of tea a
cup of coffee can I ask what's the most
you've ever spent on a shirt on a shirt
oh my god
left to say more than $200 yeah let's
say that okay yeah but these kinds of
local businesses are exactly the types
of places minimum wage critics argue or
often hurt most because they don't have
a corporate parent to lean on
say ipara local as a corporation
everything is turning corporate do you
think increasing the minimum wage could
accelerate that turning corporate if
they're the only ones that can take that
hit it seems logically speaking that
would be the case do you think that
there would be any issues with you know
businesses closing as a result yeah
definitely right here was casbah cafe
but that just closed rent is just going
is getting too high for all these places
to survive the trade-off is that you
know some smaller places that can absorb
that money that they would have to close
do you think that that's worth it that's
a shame but I feel like maybe there
could be like a government loan or
subsidy or something that could help
there are at least two options on our
survey that nobody chose $100 and zero
but why not abolish the minimum wage
altogether what do you think would
happen if there were no minimum wage
people people would there'd be slave
labor because people are monsters why
not get rid of the minimum wage uh
because then I think bosses might lower
you know what they give as a minimum
they would have people working for as
nothing if they could would abolition of
the minimum wage really lead to slave
labor in Silverlake and could there be
legitimate arrangements where people
work for little or no money because it
gives them the chance to gain valuable
experience or make important
professional contacts after all people
pay thousands of dollars to work state
sanctioned university sponsored
internships and many may prefer to work
in a small bookstore or a non-profit
over a fast-food job even if they are
unless so how are people who lack the
time money and dare we say privilege to
attend college supposed to get a
foothold in a job market that more or
less outlaws internships apprenticeships
volunteering and other customizable
arrangements that simply aren't worth
$15 an hour to any employer people will
work at they're desperate to work I
work for less if I had to in a pinch
some say I have those people they
shouldn't be allowed to say yeah work
for three bucks an hour I mean they can
on the low but not legally no not like a
regular business but yeah if you want to
give me five bucks to run an errand for
you I might do it yeah you want to buy
me coffee right now I'm taking it in
fact please do